sie haben sieben jahre mit rot grün
regiert wie groß sind die inhaltlichen
hindernisse für ein grün rot rotes
bündnis sie jetzt nicht die großen
hindernisse aber ich halte nichts von
solchen spekulationen hat mich schon
gewundert dass die vorsitzende der spd
jetzt sagt sie können sie sich auch
vorstellen unter einer grünen kanzler
grünen kanzlerin mit zu regieren wenn
ich zur zeit die umfragen anschaue da
landet diese kombination grün rot rot
bei anfang 40 das ist keine mehrheit und
nun würde ich sagen ist das nicht die
wahlzeit werden bundestagswahl erleben
die modi union antreten muss ohne
diejenige die ihr zurzeit die hoch
beschert nämlich ohne frau merkel aber
hätten sie lieber grün rot oder schwarz
grün ich würde sagen wir spekulieren
nicht wir warten erstmal ab
herr johnston wenn sie mich fragen ob
wir wenn wir die chance hätten die
kanzlerin wurde den kanzler zu stellen
darauf leichtfertig verzichten würden
das werten wir mit sicherlich nicht dass
wir fürs land also wenn es eine wenn es
eine mehrheit gibt für grün rot rot
verstehe ich dann ist herr trittin für
diese möglich